the man accused of murdering a young
mother in her home right in front of her
baby threatened to kill her before at
least that's according to the family of
Michaela Adams and police say her
ex-boyfriend Michael Ricks stabbed her
to death last Tuesday night in her home
Victoria Saha joining us tonight with an
update on the baby and the family
Ryan Denise
your old Michaela
as she wishes her daughter could have
found a way out sooner of out of an
abusive relationship she hopes her
daughter's murder is a wake-up call for
other victims of domestic violence
go baby
eight month old baby Amora is in the
care of her grandparents Monica and
Donald minor every day I tell her we all
tell her how much Michaela loves her she
was covered in blood when we found her
mom on the evening of September 13th
Monica Miner came home to find her
bathroom window broken into she says she
found her daughter 20 year old Michaela
Adams laying in a pool of blood right
next to Baby Amora who miraculously
wasn't hurt as soon as I seen my
daughter on the ground and all the blood
I knew Michael did it I was begging her
not to die minor tells us her daughter
was in an abusive relationship with 24
year old Michael Ricks the two live
together in San Diego for a while he was
also the father of Amora Michaela's told
me he's choked her he's Jugger by her
hair he's pulled her literally out of
bed while she was sleeping in June she
finally escaped to Las Vegas for good
but Miner says Rick sent her threats
using fake social media accounts he kept
saying he was on his way or he would say
that he was here and he was watching us
she says Adams had restraining orders
against Ricks in California and was in
the process of filing one in Nevada do
you think in your opinion whether there
was even a restraining order here in
Nevada it would have stopped him
regardless he would have went to any
length and extent to get to Michaela
because if he couldn't have her no one
was going to save nuts CEO Liz
ordenberger says protective orders don't
always protect you from an abuser a
restraining order is as good as the
police department that is going to
enforce it that narcissistic and
elements of that batter or personality
that allow them the ability to strangle
you are the same things that are now
going to push them towards murdering you
as for Adams's family the coups and
Cuddles that come from baby Amora are
comforting but a heartbreaking reminder
that her mom's life was taken too soon
luckily
was spared and
she's going to be the legacy of Michaela
ortenberger says Adams did the right
thing by leaving but typically the first
three to 12 months are when an attacker
can Strike Back Ricks is in jail in San
Diego waiting to be extradited back to
Las Vegas Denise